no
[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en español
hace 25 años en 1996 concluyó
formalmente la guerra civil en guatemala
uno de los conflictos sangrientos más
graves de la historia de américa central
más de un millón de desplazados
aproximadamente 200.000 muertos y sobre
todo la historia de miles de niños
secuestrados robados a sus padres
biológicos que 25 años después siguen
luchando por encontrar a aquellos que
les dieron vida precisamente para hablar
sobre esta historia tenemos y saludamos
en distancia allá en bruselas bélgica
mariela ese ere calling fanon mariela
bienvenida a esta escala en parís
es un placer tenerla con nosotros aunque
sea a distancia mariela sus apellidos en
sí mismos hacen parte o hablan de la
historia que usted ha vivido
en el 87
efectivamente usted nace en guatemala es
de origen guatemalteco y sin saberlo sin
que su madre lo sepa es adoptado en 1990
87 y es trasladada a bruselas bélgica
donde vive con sus padres adoptivos
y esta historia
qué es lo que es pero cómo vive usted
esta situación pasan algunos años antes
de que usted se empiece a dar cuenta de
que algo no funciona correctamente entre
su historia biológica y la vida con sus
padres adoptivos
la historia que conoció de madre
biológica
[Música]
pero pregunto
yo quiero saber
quiere decir
tenían en ese momento a usted 14 años
que es lo que le cuentan a su madre
biológica las autoridades de guatemala
mientras que usted ya formalmente hace
parte de una nueva vida
yo tengo dudas pero más preguntas sobre
mis raíces
a mi mamá le lleva mamá yo quiero saber
quiénes sois que quiero encontrar la
verdad de verdad de mi mamá
y su madre de ese momento se le da una
fotografía que es lo que le permite
usted de empezar dijéramos a tejer hacia
atrás lo que es su historia biológica
a mí yo recibí mi expediente de arousal
de la parte de mis perspectivas y muchas
de errores las cosas falsas
de esta manera yo
quiero encontrar
pasan los años usted ya tiene 30 años
tiene dos hijos un día la más grande de
ella su hija que tiene en ese momento
cinco años le dice a usted mamá soy una
india de guatemala y eso para usted es
una especie de señal de alarma que le
empieza a hacer avanzar a plantearse
mucho más cuestiones es la primera es el
primera ocasión en la que usted viaja a
guatemala en ese momento
es la primera vez que como como mujer yo
me pregunto quién estoy ahorita en este
tipo de saber porque es una parte de la
historia de mis hijos y mi hija me
pregunto mamá yo quiero saber si yo soy
indígena de personalidad pero es
imposible porque ya tienes los ojos
azules y es rubia ya para este momento
es claro para mí que es
empieza usted a buscar y encuentra usted
a su madre biológica a lorena de la
clave haremos posteriormente en detalle
el encuentro usted en 2017 a finales
viejos tienen 2017 guatemala y es en ese
momento que empiece a escribirse con el
encuentro en enero del 2018 es correcto
a contar con la ayuda de una periodista
de marcha en el salón
cuénteme un poco sobre esto lorena
cuenta de su perdón cuéntenos un poco
sobre esto mariela porque sin duda
alguna es una búsqueda complicada es una
especie de tela de araña en la que usted
se tiene que meter que dura varios años
háblenos un poco de esta situación
pero el primero no tenemos apoyo
institucional para aplicar nosotros
adoptados perdimos la idioma y no hablo
español
sólo después tres años y media antes yo
no puedo hablar nada
pero también qué
para leer y entender los expedientes
necesito tener un apoyo
y ese apoyo quien se lo da concretamente
en el primer hoyo encontraron artículos
de cebra tales talón
sobre una investigación de
adopciones ilegales radicales
y yo lo contacte y se vayan me ayudó
metros en contacto también por marcar
hábito presente de arica con temática
técnica mental
que tiene un programa de búsqueda para
la vida
mariela antes de seguir avanzando en
esta parte de su historia quisiera yo
evocar el caso de un personaje sórdido
porcenaje una mujer ofelia de gamas
cuñada del que fuera entre los años 80
cuando usted es sacada de guatemala de
el general óscar mejía víctores que es
en ese momento el dictador de guatemala
guatemala vivió una sucesión de
dictaduras hasta casi el final de la
guerra civil el es dictador y jefe de
las fuerzas armadas del estado entre
1983 y 1986 pero esa criminal y la
palabra la pongo yo criminal esta mujer
ofelia de hamás es la cuñada de el
dictador óscar mejía y al mismo tiempo
es la directora del orfelinato donde
usted había estado ubicada es correcto
sí pero en mi caso es el testimonio de
mi madre biológica
qué es lo que le dice su madre biológica
cuando usted le escribe para decirle
aquí estoy mamá
ella me mandó otras detalles debiste
hola a mi hija a los altares
y ella
es muy emotivo sin duda alguna recordar
estas situaciones no lo dudo
no lo dije y le hicieron creer que obama
está y que yo estaba enterada un compló
xx
y cuando usted empiece a escribirse con
su madre incluso antes de encontrarla
usted le dice mamá no estoy muerta ya
este propósito
me gustaría mariela recuerden no sé
usted va a publicar próximamente antes
de que acabe este año 2021 un libro que
lleva precisamente ese título mamá no
estoy muerta
cuál es el objetivo del libro que usted
publicará y con ese título que
precisamente fue lo que en aquel
entonces le escribió usted a su madre
biológica
es un metraje para mi mamá en guatemala
para decir yo soy aquí soy vidente pero
también es una mensaje de libertad como
mujer como adoptada porque yo soy rico
en vida
pero también en el libro y voy a tener
detalles de estas aves
de los mecanismos
una persona profesional que pudieron
apoyar en la búsqueda
vamos a hablar precisamente de quienes
le ayudaron en la búsqueda pero vamos
también a hablar de aquellos que son la
cadena precisamente que permite este
tipo de robos este tipo de situaciones
ilegales me refiero concretamente a una
organización muy importante que se llama
hacer puente es una organización que
funcionaba en aquel entonces no sé si
siga todavía funcionando en la
actualidad es la asociación belga
encargada de tramitar las demandas
precisamente de adopción de niños
guatemaltecos y supongo de otras
nacionalidades por familias
guatemaltecas háblenos de esta
asociación hacer puente
no puedes decir mucho porque tenemos un
caso en la justicia de bélgica
necesito de respetar la presunción de
inocencia de las personas sospechosas
pero sí con muchos adoptados que fueron
adoptadas para
en nuestro público habrá comprendido que
estamos frente a una situación una
especie de red de telaraña en la que se
mezclan nombres falsos y nombres
verdaderos adopciones legales basadas en
una raíz ilegal muchos intereses una
cadena de mando que abarca al conjunto
del estado guatemalteco autoridades
internacionales y sobre todo corrupción
y dinero mucho dinero mariela cuánto
pagaba una familia de padres que querían
adoptar a un niño pensando que era una
adopción legal evidentemente por poder
adoptar a una niña o un niño de
guatemala- cuánto se pagaba en ese
entonces
en primero si yo puedo decir el 30 que
es cinco mil dólares en los años 80 pero
enorme pero la gente en guatemala
europa
y tenían la información sobre
las salud del niño que es muy mal o
puede tener
más persona para cuidarlo de esta manera
los padres adoptivos pagaron entre 5.000
y 15.000 dólares en los años 80
al 35 y 15.000 dólares en aquel entonces
es decir que para el estado guatemalteco
para las autoridades del estado
automático era un buen negocio esto
finalmente un muy buen negocio
por cierto
muy rápidamente usted a partir de que
conoce a su madre decíamos en dinero del
2018 empieza a avanzar precisamente todo
el trabajo para hacer que avance la
búsqueda de los niños robados a sus
padres y ha creado una organización
fundación raíces perdidas cuál es el
objetivo de esta fundación mariela
la sociedad se enteró en un principio
estamos un colectivo después la
selección y ahorita una predicación
2021 pero fue creada en 2007
para encontrar a las madres biológicas y
porque no existe apoyo a distintos solar
y el principio
de tener la esperanza también por los
adoptados es decir que es una
posibilidad encontrar familias
encontrar a sus familias sobre todo
sabiendo que se extienden
aproximadamente varios miles de niños y
por consejo varias miles de familias que
fueron afectadas por esta situación
y bueno pues estamos llegando ya al
final de esta escala en parís no me
queda sino agradecerle a mariela ese ere
colom fund su presencia en esta escala
en parálisis muchas gracias desde allá
desde bruselas a ustedes les damos una
próxima cita aquí la próxima semana en
otra escala en parís
[Música]